it is warm here a Haven for many who
can't afford to heat their homes Laura
is trying to advise them but is also
struggling herself I read the other day
that the average is about 90 Pence an
hour to have eating on so we sit there
in an evening and we calculate how many
90 pencils we can afford and
just how long you can have your heated
up for foreign
[Music]
help was on offer here in Stoke-on-Trent
as part of a national day of action on
fuel poverty
in London just stop oil protesters lent
their support with a short demonstration
in Harrods
across the country campaigners held
rallies demanding more government help
the obvious Solutions are to transition
away from gas towards cheap renewable
energy but also to make sure that we're
insulating people's homes so they're not
just wasting energy every time they they
put it on the Westminster government
says they're committing substantial
funding to improving the Energy
Efficiency of homes as well as giving
households unprecedented financial
support but for some it's still not
enough I've not had the eating on at all
yet and it's
it's already double the amount you know
what I'd normally pay for the same thing
so it's just lights and stuff like that
you're thinking if you did put the
heating on well of course it's going to
go Sky High and then it's a case of
choosing dye we'll do it you know put
the radiators on and I'd rather eat yeah
I worry a large batch of gas
[Music]
um
as soon as you place on it goes down
that fast I've been I was saving through
the summit uh make it last through the
winter and it's going that quick bang
and that's not having it on all the
times just like half an hour in the
morning half an hour at night for those
already struggling it is about to get
worse campaigners say there must be even
more support for those most in need
Lisa Dowd Sky News Staffordshire